hey David there was recently a
controversy about Michael Bloomberg
being called an oligarch do you believe
Michael Bloomberg is an oligarch so what
is an oligarchy generally defined an
oligarch is a rich business leader with
a lot of political influence now by that
definition of course Michael Bloomberg
is an oligarch in the United States the
term is more commonly used in Russia and
there's a sort of pejorative sense to
the word but that's okay we'll still use
it and and and use it for our analysis
here if you have money to buy your way
to ten percent support in a Democratic
primary jumping in very very late you
are an Oleg arc in some sense and
Michael Bloomberg is he's still better
than Trump but in this strict definition
he is absolutely an oligarch now we have
to recognize that the circumstances for
oligarchs in the United States are very
different than they are in places like
Russia and Ukraine where oligarchs have
a degree of control there that they
simply do not have here individual rich
dudes with private armies in Russia and
Ukraine that is different and I know
people will say well the president gets
these mercenaries I get it but we are
not talking about the same thing
Bloomberg is an oligarch in that he can
use his vast wealth to buy his way into
the election but he still needs to
successfully deploy the money to
convince voters to support him otherwise
he won't get a single delegate he can't
simply buy his way into office in the
same way that a Russian Petro
billionaire can you can buy your way
into an ambassadorship and we see it
done quite quite often a lot of the
difference is really a difference of
degree right the level of corruption the
u.s. is hugely corrupt in many ways but
it is not nearly as corrupt as Russia is
in this sense so I you know we've talked
before why are they called oligarchs in
Russia and just billionaires in the
United States and that's a fair question
but there is a difference and it's not
just Russia and Ukraine the term
oligarch is less used in some African
nations but it would certainly apply
there as well
in some of the Islamic theocracies of
the Middle East the term oligarch is not
used that frequently but it would also
apply in a way that it simply doesn't in
the United States but for the standards
of the United States for the level of
corruption we have which is it corrupt
but it's not what exists in other
countries the u.s. you can actually look
at the corruption rankings and see where
we are Michael Bloomberg is an oligarch
by any reasonable American
interpretation of the term but we still
have a very different situation here
than we do in many other countries the
people who went crazy when Michael
Bloomberg was called an oligarch I think
it was on MSNBC or whatever come on the
guy is essentially an oligarch although
that just means something different here
than it means and for example Ukraine or
Georgia or the country or Russia almost
all American journalism is controlled by
a few massive corporations and news
voice is a one of a kind mobile app that
tracks the bias and corporate interests
that infuse the news stories we consume
every day and it's totally free to use
it's a great tool to have on your phone
news voice is not funded by advertisers
or corporate investors the platform is
supported by contributions from users
like you the news voice app will have
some really excellent new features soon
specifically for the 2020 election but
they're wanting to expand their team of
independent journalists in order to keep
everything running they're offering
special rewards to anyone who wants to
give to their new Kickstarter campaign
which can be found at news voice dot-com
/ kik giving a contribution will come
with rewards like insider access to
group chats with news voice staff
members as well as access to a variety
of special features go see what news
voice is all about